ce que l'on avait appelé en tout cas le
printemps de Pékin avait pourtant donné
le signal de l'effondrement d'un certain
nombre de régimes totalitaires à l'est
le gouvernement chinois a rappelé il y a
peu de temps sa volonté de réprimer
toute véléité démocratique conséquence
de cette marche arrière un isolement
diplomatique que les Chinois tentent de
rompre en ce moment en multipliant les
contacts et les invitations un
anniversaire au moment où sououvre à
Paris une exposition les Chinois eux ont
déjà protesté Francine Raymon il y a un
an le printemps de Pékin était sur le
point d'éclater les télévisions du monde
entier venu couvrir la visite de Michael
Gorbatchev en Chine allit montrer à une
opinion internationale stupéfaite la
révolution pour la liberté des étudiants
chinois le 4 juin C n'est fini du rêve
de liberté l'armée reçoit l'ordre de
tirer c'est le massacre de la place Tien
Anmen répression arrestation une chape
de plomb s'abat sur la Chine les caméras
sont partis d'autres images choc ont
fait oublier
celle-là à Paris sur le toit de l'ARGE
de défense une exposition de photos pour
se souvenir que la Chine est toujours
une dictature en janvier dernier Pékin
levait symboliquement la loi martiale
les États-Unis et le Japon renoué des
relations diplomatiques et commerciales
avec la Chine depuis la Communauté
européenne a levé ses sanctions et le
gouvernement français accorde de nouveau
sa garantie au crédits commerciaux vers
la Chine quand des jeunes manifestent
pour la liberté nous devons être à leur
côté instinctivement le volte français
l'a été et alors nous allons l'oublier
parce qu'il y a quelques contrats à
signer enfin vraiment vraiment cela ne
veut pas dire qu'il faut rompre avec la
Chine je crois qu'il est toujours
dangereux de rompre il a un gouvernement
en Chine il faut avoir des relation
normale avec la Chine il faut faire
pression sur la Chine mais la pression
doit être établie à tout moment et au
nom de nos peuples comme nous l'avons
fait avec l'Afrique du Sud comme nous
l'avons fait insuffisamment parfois avec
les républiques d'Europe de l'Est comme
nous l'avons fait avec le Chili en tout
cas c'est la France que Ching l'une des
figures du mouvement pour la démocratie
des étudiants chinois depuis 10 mois par
les autorités de Pékin a choisi pour se
réfugier